bonjour à toutes et à tous ces bals et
aux news l'émission qui fait des news
avec du vieux en moins d'une semaine et
demie on nous a sorti quatre articles
sur des sur des fossiles d'hominidés sur
l'étude de fossiles d'hominidés sur
l'évolution humaine et chacun d'entre
eux était accompagné d'un vin d'un petit
couplet de la presse et des médias qui
déclarait évidemment réécrire l'histoire
de l'évolution humaine vous avez donc
vous avez vu passer très certainement si
vous vous intéressez évidemment à
l'évolution humaine
vous avez vu passer très certainement un
nombre incalculable de titre put à
cliquer qui vous disaient l'évolution
humaine vient d'être réécrit checking de
tri comme ils disent en anglais enfin
voilà et et honnêtement je les ai lues
ces quatre articles et ils sont corrects
mais il y en a aucun qui réécrit
l'évolution humaine
soyons tout à fait clair à chaque fois
qu'un nouvel article sort sur
l'évolution humaine
on ne fait que raffinée l'image qu'on a
de l'évolution humaine il y en a aucun
qui révolutionne l'évolution humaine
j'ai lu ces quatre études et il n'y a
pas de quoi révolutionner le l'arbre de
l'évolution humaine où j'ai même envie
de dire que seules elles ont certains
défauts bas que je vais pointer du doigt
en fait c'est pas des gros gros défaut
évidemment c'est de la bonne recherche
toujours mais quand même enfin le dire
est ce que ça valait vraiment le coup de
faire autant de tapage médiatique ça par
contre bas c'est à chaque fois la grande
question est ce que ça vaut tout le
tapage médiatique qu'on fait à chaque
fois mais c'est la grande question à
chaque fois qu'on parle d'évolution
humaine donc le premier article c'est
une description d'un bébé
australopithèques us donc d'un bébé oui
alors celui-là en plus dans les dents
les la presse dans la presse c'était le
lucie voilà parce que c'est
australopithecus afarensis nancéen
juvénile de la même espèce que l'uci
s'est pas lucie et à l'arrière n'est
qu'il appelle le bébé de lucie alors ça
ça m'a fait bondir au plafond alors ceci
dit je me demandais d'où venez
l'histoire que l'uci était enceinte
enfin que l'uci avait un bébé quand elle
est morte
je commence à comprendre d'où elle vient
cette histoire c'est parce
qu'apparemment ce spécimen qui s'appelle
dikika donc des ics à un aussi je crois
que c'est son numéro de son petit label
c'est délicat 1-1 donc surnommé dikika
je crois qu'il ya certaines personnes
qui le surnomme qui le surnomme le bébé
de l'uci voilà des trucs ils ont même
pas vécu en même temps je veux dire ils
ont vécu plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'années d'intervalle au moins plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'années
d'intervalle mais bon à part ça
voilà le bébé lui si bref
australopithecus afarensis il s'agit
donc d'un juvénile d'un juvénile très
très jeune d'australopithecus afarensis
d'âge est de trois ans je crois ouais de
deux ou trois ans je crois ils ont
réussi à dallas
à lui donner un âge parce qu'ils ont
regardé les dents tout simplement vous
regardez quelle danse ont sorti vous
vous avez à peu près l'âge de du gamin
qu'elle danse qu'elle dents de lait sont
en éruption et vous verrez que sont en
train de sortir et puis vous saurez
l'âge de votre gamin quoi donc donc un
bébé australopithèques us et donc ils
ont étudié son cerveau et son cerveau il
a des caractéristiques d'hominidés
moderne donc d'humains et il a des
caractéristiques de singe et donc la
grande découverte
la grande découverte de cet article a
été justement la découverte du fait que
son que le cerveau de ce jus bénilde
australopithecus afarensis à des
caractères intermédiaire entre homos et
les grands singes
ouais j'ai fait j'ai pas mal sur ligne
et j'ai pas mal surligner il ya
notamment cette phrase que j'ai
surligner qui dit que voilà on qui nous
parle d'ancêtres encore une fois donc il
nous dit qu australopithèques us
pourrait être ancestrales aux hominidés
enfin à homo aux lignes à la lignée homo
sans citer de référence 1
quand même je veux dire avec tout les
mêmes qu'on voit sur internet de gens
qui disent donner vos sources
mais c'est pas ça le fait pas ça le truc
important de cet article le truc
important de cet article c'est qu'est ce
qui fait de ce cerveau un cerveau un peu
entrepris un peu humain est un peu grand
singe et bien c'est la présence du sucre
us lui natus donc ce sur tous les natus
il est présent chez les chimpanzés et il
est absent chez chez l'homme moderne
donc ça c'est un truc qui fait que le
cerveau de dickie cas est relativement
primitif et c'était une question ça peut
sembler tout à fait anecdotique mais
c'est une question qui a été en suspens
depuis la découverte du tout premier
australopithèques qui était l'enfant de
tongs et qui avait déjà
une impression de la boîte crânienne à
l'intérieur préserver donc on avait déjà
essayé de repérer ce sulpice du natus
chez chez le tout premier
australopithèques qui avait été
découvert est déjà là il y avait eu
énormément de débat parce que c'est pas
du tout facile de voir ce sulpice les
natus parce qu'il est situé à côté
d'autres sion ben vous voyez qu'il ya
d'autres sion notamment le lci sichi qui
est en fait le sillon attendez que je
trouve son petit nom le sea lion le call
car 1 voilà donc le lc il est juste à
côté il peut être confondu avec le sud
plus lu natus il ya aussi la ici ce que
vous voyez là ce trait blanc alors c'est
représenter comme n'appartenant pas au
cerveau et c'est normal puisque c'est en
fait la suture entre le pas entre le
pariétal et l'occiput halles c'est la
suture l'android est donc cette future
l'android elle est très souvent confondu
avec le sud cusm et natus parce qu'en
plus vous voyez qu'elle suit à peu près
la même forme en elle que le sud plus ni
accuse donc il y avait un énorme débat
qui qui traînait dans la littérature
depuis 100 ans maintenant sur les
australopithèques est ce qu'ils on a su
le cusm du natus ou pas dickie cas
répond à la question
il en avait à au moins quand il avait
trois ans ce qui veut pas dire qu'ils en
avaient encore un l et adultes mais bon
au moins on sait qu'à trois ans il en
avait un et la raison pour laquelle on
ne voit pas chez l'adulte
c'est parce que chez l'adulte il ya en
fait le les ménages deviennent trop
épais et du coup le set l'impression du
sud plus lu nature ceux du suc uslu
natus père chez l'adulte en fait même si
le sillon est présent chez l'adulte il
est complètement
il est complètement cachée par le fait
qu'il ya trop de ménages en fait entre
le cerveau et la boîte crânienne
donc voilà ça confirme au moins qui
avait un traître est un caractère très
tracy mais est-ce que voilà seulement
que je cherche simiesque
c'est dans le cerveau de
australopithecus afarensis maintenant il
ya une autre conclusion c'est le fait
qu'il selon eux le cerveau de dickie cas
en fait est très petit pour un cerveau
deux pour un cerveau de cet âge ce qui
veut dire que enfin il est plus petit
que ce qu'on s'attendrait à voir sur 1
par rapport à un cerveau de chimpanzés
donc ça veut dire que chez
australopithecus afarensis le cerveau
grandissait plus lentement que chez les
chimpanzés
ce qui est exactement le cas aussi chez
l'homme moderne chez l'homme moderne le
cerveau grandi beaucoup plus lentement
que chez le chimpanzé donc chez l'homme
moderne c'est notamment dû au fait que
ben faut que le bébé puisse sortir
dévoua pelvienne et du coup donc pendant
l'accouchement faut pas que la tête
restent coincés et c'est extrêmement
technique que comme raison et du coup
voilà le cerveau ralentit la croissance
du cerveau est ralentie chez l'homme
moderne et du coup ça veut dire que chez
le australopithèques us selon eux la
croissance du cerveau étaient ralentis
aussi par contre même s'il avait eu un
cerveau normal donc un cerveau de la
taille de celui d'un chimpanzé comme
celui d'un chimpanzé quoi qui
grandissait vite ils auraient quand même
pu passer par les voies pelvienne donc
c'est ce que j'ai souri surligner là ce
qui veut dire qu'en grohl ça veut dire
que l'évolution des voix l'évolution
d'un petit d'un cerveau qui grandit
lentement n'est pas corrélé à
l'évolution des voix pelvienne donc ça
s'est relativement intéressant ça veut
dire qu'il n'ya pas il n'y a pas eu de
pression c'est pas le les voies
pelvienne qui ont exercé une pression
évolutive une pression de sélection
contre une croissance rapide du cerveau
le cerveau a commencé à ralentir sa
croissance avant que les voies pelvienne
ne devienne un problème
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya une raison
plus profonde à ça même si on la connaît
pas il faut bien admettre qu'on sait
parce que quelle est cette raison plus
profonde
peut-être que ça permet une apprend un
apprentissage plus long peut-être que ça
permet d'économiser des ressources aussi
parce qu'un cerveau ça en a consommé
énormément de ressources donc peut-être
que ça a servi à icônes
miser des ressources on ne sait pas
évidemment là l'hypothèse privilégiée
celle de l'apprentissage parce que quand
on parle de cerveau on est mieux parler
d'intelligence que d'autres choses donc
voilà et maintenant le problème que j'ai
le gros problème que j'ai avec cette
étude là c'est ça c'est voilà la
croissance du cerveau d'un chimpanzé
donc vous avez l'âge ici la taille du
cerveau là vous avez la croissance d'un
cerveau de chimpanzés ici donc la taille
adulte est atteint à peu près 3 4 ans en
gros la taille du cerveau adulte est à
peu près atteinte à peu près 3 4 ans
voici la croissance d'un cerveau humain
et vous voyez que la taille adulte est
atteinte à à peu près 5 6 ans et voici
vos australopithèques 1 2 3 4
donc 3 4 c les adultes mâles et femelles
1 2 ce sont les juvéniles donc dikika et
puis le deuxième
le deuxième j'ai pas j'ai oublié de
présenter le deuxième c'est pas grave
c'est son petit frère quoi le voilà le
deuxième est le deuxième il s'appelle
qui s'appelle il s'appelle ils ont ils
lui ont pas donné non si il s'appelle
hael 333 105 voilà donc il a elle
vraiment un joli petit nom vous trouvez
pas donc bref ses deux enfants de lucie
donc ils ont ils ont leur petit cerveau
ça va devenir une nouvelle insulte
espèce de fils de lucie donc ses deux
enfants de lui si ils ont un cerveau qui
est là et les adultes ils ont un cerveau
qui est là et maintenant faut regarder
ce graphe et se dire que ça ça veut dire
que la croissance du cerveau des
australopithèques était plus similaire à
celle de l'homme qu'à celle du chimpanzé
voilà c'est un peu ça mon problème ça
demande un peu les yeux de la foi quoi
donc effectivement ils ont à peu près
deux ans voilà ce que je disais à peu
près de trois ans et effectivement ça
tombe dans la partie basse de la
variation du chimpanzé
ce qui veut dire que c'était un peu plus
petit que ce qu'on s'attend à voir chez
le chimpanzé moyens mais bon quand même
ça demande pas mal les yeux de la foi
donc après ils ont utilisé la taille
relative du cerveau donc en pourcentage
de la taille du cerveau adulte
donc ça vient un peu technique mais bon
c'est très simple c'est juste la taille
du cerveau observé sur la taille sur la
taille du cerveau adulte en pourcentage
de taille du cerveau adulte et donc là
une fois de plus vous avez le chimpanzé
s'agrandit très très vite et ça atteint
vite sa taille adulte et vous avez lu ma
s'agrandit plus lentement et ça atteint
plus lentement sa taille adulte ont
encore une fois entre 5 et 6 ans et donc
effectivement là si on si on met
australopithecus afarensis donc les deux
bébés qui sont là et qu'on l'aimé ici là
effectivement il tombe définitivement du
côté bleu et non plus du côté vert donc
est ce que pour autant ça veut dire que
c'est gagné
une fois de plus le problème vous voyez
ça c'est le sait la marge c'est pas la
marge d'erreur mais c'est la marge de
variation
voilà envers là
et vous voyez que la marge de variation
entre le chimpanzé et l'homme elle se
recouvrent horriblement et donc il ya
une chance non négligeable que vous
voyez cette partie là en noir là c'est
la probabilité non négligeable que tout
ce qu'ils racontent juste au dessus soit
faux voilà donc c'est embêtant c'est
extrêmement embêtant alors en moyenne ça
marche
dans l'absolu il ya quand même une
probabilité que ça marche pas voilà donc
et ça c est donc ça c'est embêtant donc
c'est pour ça que je dis ça demande un
peu les yeux de la foi quand même pour
pour y croire et niveau révolution du
niveau révolution delà de ce qu'on sait
de l'évolution humaine et c'est disons
que s'il avait eu un peu plus de donner
voilà ça demandera un peu plus de
données et notamment
je vais essayer de revenir au graff ça
demanderait un peu plus de donner ça
demandera dans le futur surtout bah
justement des australopithèques qui
tombe dans certains terrains valent
entre 2 et 6 ans où là on s'attend à
voir une grosse différence parce
qu'entre 2 et 6 entre 2 et 6 ans
s'attend à ce qu'ils aient atteint leur
taille adulte
s'ils suivent la courbe des chimpanzés
alors que si on est face à quelque chose
de plus ou mini des dents dans la
croissance bas là on s'attend à ce
qu'ils aient pas encore leur taille
adulte
donc en fait sa demande est ce que dans
le futur on trouve des australopithèques
qui ont entre 2 et 6 ans voilà donc
affaire à suivre
comme c'est généralement le cas
d'ailleurs avec ce avec les découvertes
un autre article qui a prétendu
révolutionner l'évolution humaine
c'est la découverte de protéines domo
hanter ses sorts qui a permis de faire
une nouvelle phylogénie
vous passez tous les détails techniques
parce que de toute façon même moi je ne
les comprends pas mais ça a permis de
faire une nouvelle phylogénie
d'augmenter c'est ça et grosse surprise
homo antecessor et groupe frère de
sapiens plus néandertal plus denisot va
évidemment je suis sarcastique quand je
dis surprise évidemment que ce n'est pas
une surprise
là où cet article est par contre une
surprise c'est qu'ils ont aussi réussi à
avoir de l'adn domoïque en fa de l'adn
des protéines des séquences protéique
d'homo erectus et voilà le générique de
fin
voilà ça c'est l'article en entier ça
c'est la phylogénie voyez générique de
fin il ya rien n'y a pire il n'y a pas
de fil au génie d'homo erectus publié
dans l'article si vous voulez voir une
phylogénie d'homo erectus faut aller
dans les dents les données
supplémentaires
faux faux faux click & click & click &
click et voilà on passe le générique de
fin on passe les figures supplémentaire
et on finit éventuellement par tombée
sur une file au génie qui inclut homo
erectus peut être un jour je me rappelle
l'avoir vu je sais que je les ai vus
elle est là et là enfin on tombe sur un
mot erectus alors apparemment ils disent
qu'ils n'avaient pas assez de données
que du coup homo erectus ça donnait pas
un bon résultat ça donnait pas un très
bon résultat donc ça c'est voilà le truc
c'est que cette pour que ce soit un beau
résultat en gros faut que ici il y est
écrit plus de 90 plus de 0,90 0,61 quand
on fait une analyse bayésienne donc ça
c'est les probabilités postérieur et
c'est une mesure de la solidité des
branches de votre arbre phylogénétique
et si ces probabilités postérieur sont
pas entre 90 et 100 et entre 0,90 et un
donc 90% quoi bein en gros considère que
c'est un tri pousser un arbre pourri
j'avais à parler en anglais c'est un
trip oury j'allais faire du franglais
donc c'est un arbre pourri voilà donc là
il considérait que c'était un peu trop
pourri pour aller dans la dans le corps
de texte mais bon ça aurait été quand
même intéressant de le voir parce que
quand même dû
là on a des protéines d'homo erectus
pourquoi c'est pas dans le pourquoi
cette arme n'est pas dans le corps de
texte quoi donc bref et homo erectus
encore une fois grosse surprise ils
arrivent en groupe frère de néandertal
et l'homo sapiens denisot va donc c'est
pas non plus une grosse grosse surprise
c'est exactement là qu'on s'attend à le
trouver
donc niveau réécriture c'est pareil on
ça se pose là le truc qui me déçoit le
plus avec cet article c'est j'aurais
bien aimé voir ou homo erectus se
mettait par rapport à augmenter ses
sorts là par contre parce que là je me
serais attendu à voir augmenter ses
sorts se brancher la ici donc homo
antecessor plus proche de sapiens et
néandertal denisot va et homo erectus
groupe frère de vente et ses soeurs plus
simples aux plus denisot va mais ça
aurait pu
ça aurait pu
tombé autrement et du coup ça aurait pu
donner un signal nouveau une nouvelle
phylogénie des humains un autre truc que
je m'attendais à voir c'était une
discussion de loyers de l'eau et
d'albert gagnent 6 parce que homo
heidelbergensis il ya à peu près il ya
combien c'était quand cet article là
c'était en 2014 en 2014 et dahlberg m6
ils ont trouvé de l'adn et il avait fait
une belle phylogénie d' homo
heidelbergensis avec de l'adn donc aux
moyens delberghe n 6 qui venait de sima
de los masos
donc on met des albères gagnent 6 de
sima de los masos il avait trouvé de
l'adn il en avait fait un arbre
phylogénétique il avait trouvé qu'il
était groupe frère de denisova voyez
comme quoi ça peut là pour le coup homo
heidelbergensis d'espagne groupe frère
de denisova de russie alors que
néandertal est juste là parce que je
rappelle que dahlberg n62 atapuerca
c'est censé être un prêt néandertaliens
donc normalement il est censé se
brancher la côte et de néandertal et là
on le voit branché de l'autre côté à
côté de denisot va littéralement à
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres de là
on est censé se trouver du coup donc ça
voilà cet article là ils avaient ils
avaient ce il avait suggéré des
résultats nouveau est assez
impressionnant donc ça veut pas dire que
c'est vrai peut-être que c'est juste
encore une fois les séquences d adn
anciens sont souvent très très courte et
ça donne ça donne assez souvent des
résultats très partiels et pas toujours
très très solide mais voilà c'est ça ça
aurait été quelque chose que j'aurais
voulu voir dans cet article une
comparaison avec le berghain 6 surtout
que leur leur antécécent or il vient de
sima de los masos donc il vient aussi
d'espagne et c'est aussi considéré comme
un prêt néandertaliens du coup cet homo
antecessor enfin évidemment il ya un
débat pour savoir si c'est l'ancêtre
hantée ses sorts et de tous les et de
tous les humains ou est ce que c'est un
malade il est souvent considéré comme un
prêt néandertaliens se teinter ses
soeurs donc là pour le coup ça ne
soutient pas cette position
effectivement mais j'aurais bien aimé
voir quand même et de le berghain 6 et
homo erectus tout ça dans le même arbre
ça a été intéressant ça aurait été
intéressant en disant que là pour le
coup ça ne soutient pas hanter ses sorts
comme un prêt néandertaliens mais ça a
été intéressant du coup de voir s'ils
étaient peut-être plus heureux liao
moyens rectus du coup ou s'ils étaient
plus reliés ou ou tomber de le berghain
six là dedans bref ça ça laisse un petit
arrière-goût de pas fini voilà cette
étude donc et elle aurait plus là pour
le coup réécrire l'histoire de
l'évolution humaine cette étude
ou du moins ou du moins secoué les bases
de ce qu'on croit savoir sur l'évolution
humaine mais bon bah ils sont ils n'ont
pas poussé le bouchon suffisamment loin
voilà bon peut-être parce que encore une
fois les données sont très partiel c'est
s'aider données les données
paléogénétique et paléo protéique c'est
souvent c'est souvent très parcellaires
et on peut pas faire tout ce qu'on veut
donc j'imagine que c'est ce qui leur est
arrivé et une numéro 3 sortie le 30 mai
le crâne on a enfin daté le crâne de
broken hill le crâne de broken hill up
ouais bah c'est celui que je ne vous
montrez c'est celui que je vais vous
montrer mais voilà le crâne de broken
hill il est aussi appelé le crâne de
kaboul donc c'est un crâne de haendel
bergin 6 encore lui et ce crâne il a
enfin été datés et alors qu'on
s'imaginait qu'il était vieux de cinq
cent mille ans en fait il s'avère qu'il
est vieux que de trois cent mille ans
c'est ça la conclusion de tout ça et du
coup du coup bah ouais voilà j'ai envie
de dire je j'avais presque envie de
mettre à même de iago en train de crier
à bas ça c'est une surprise parce que là
parce que pour le coup c'est même pas
nouveau la possibilité qu'il ait trois
cent mille ans parce que dans l'arctique
les insiste beaucoup sur le fait qu'on
croyait qu'il avait cinq cent mille ans
mais c'est même pas vrai parce que en
voyant ça je me rappelle avoir ouvert
un bouquin dans ma bibliothèque genre le
premier bouquin venus dont je me
rappelais qu'il parlait du crâne de
kaboul et dans la légende de la photo du
crâne de kabou et c'était écrit vieux de
300 mille ans donc bon donc ça veut dire
que cette hypothèse elle traînait
quelque part donc là on est un petit peu
sur le on est un petit peu sur un homme
de paille là ils nous ont dit que ça
faisait cinq cent mille ans grosse
controverse par rapport à leur date de
trois cent mille ans mais en fait non il
ya des gens qui disait déjà qu'il avait
300 millions quoi après les gens qui
disaient qu'ils avaient trois cent mille
ans n'avait pas plus raison que ceux qui
disaient qu'ils avaient cinq cent mille
ans 1
que les choses soient claires il y
allait tous au pifomètre puisqu'il n'y
avait aucune date mais voilà et après
2,6 à 300 mille ans et pas non plus
c'est pas non plus une grosse surprise
puisqu'il ya
il ya le crâne de commence le crâne qui
a été découvert près de bloemfontein en
afrique du sud
son petit nom à lui c'est floris bad
voilà et qui est aussi un et d'albert
guentis certains voudraient en faire une
espèce différente mais bon il a toutes
les caractéristiques des deux
libériennes 6 et et ce crâne il à 260
milles ans donc il est même plus jeunes
bon il est moins complet par contre ça
c'est vrai et d'ailleurs puisqu'on en
parle là quelque chose et encore une
fois il ya un truc que j'aurais bien
voulu voir discuter là dedans dans cet
article c'est une comparaison avec
jebali rude
le crâne de djembé les routes qui lui
aussi à trois cent mille ans parce que
si on les compare tous les deux le crâne
de djebel i round donc le crâne de le
crâne qui a été découvert au maroc le
crâne qui a été découvert au maroc
attribuèrent homo sapiens sous sa forme
moderne et qu'on le compare au crâne de
kaboré et qu'on considère qu'ils ont
tous les deux le même âge c'est à dire
trois cent mille ans bon ben vous avez
qu à bout est ici avec sa boîte
crânienne ovale son processus sont aux
russes supra orbitaire bien proéminents
et puis ça petit son petit museau un son
micro museau de 2,6 et vous avez le
crâne de hiru d'
avec sa boîte crânienne ovale sont aux
russes supra orbitaire proéminents et
son petit museau et puis la phase un peu
vénère aussi d'ailleurs assez typique
d'heidelberg m6 donc bon il ya
évidemment des caractères qui diffèrent
et il ya aussi le voyez le le front qui
est fuyant voilà le front il est
légèrement plus redresser chez sur
djebel est rude mais il est quand même
globalement plutôt fuyant donc j'aurais
bien voulu qui parle justement de là
pour le coup c'était une application
assez directe de leur découverte de
discuter bah ouais bah du coup ça
questionne peut-être l'attribution de
certains spécimens à homo sapiens bah
non il ne dispute pas du tout que ce
soit le crâne de homo le crâne de
berthod le crâne de woods le
ils ne discutent absolument pas enfin
une il ne remet absolument pas en
question leur attribution homo sapiens
donc j'étais un petit peu séparés j'ai
été un petit peu déçue ski ski préférant
dire c'est que voilà il ya eu des
coexistence des homo sapiens et 2 et 2
et dahlberg n 6
ce qui n'est absolument pas une surprise
comme je le disais il ya il ya le crâne
de floris bad qui le disaient qu'ils qui
envoyait exactement le même signal quoi
donc bon pareil on n'est pas sûr de la
réécriture de l'évolution humaine avec
cet article non plus et enfin le dernier
le dernier qui vient d'afrique du sud
tiens justement et qui nous parle de la
contemporanéité de australopithecus part
entre opus est homo erectus donc content
pas contemporanéité qui vient de la
découverte et de la datation de ce crâne
d'un juvénile d'homo erectus juvénile
parce qu'il a des tout petits cerveaux
de cinq centimètres cubes seulement mais
qui a quand même j'ai surligner ici des
caractéristiques qui lui en font un homo
erectus et d'un autre crâne qui
appartient à part entre opus qui est pas
de doute que c'est du parent trope avec
une crête sagittale comme ça et donc ces
deux crânes ils ont ils sont datés de
deux millions d'années
donc sachant qu'il y a australopithecus
sediba qui vivait il ya deux millions
d'années sachant que sachant que
maintenant il ya homo erectus et part en
trope trouvaient dans leur cette grotte
cette crotte qui s'appelle drie mollen
qui vient d'être daté puisque c'est sa
l'article c'est une datation de la
grotte de drie mollen en plus de la
description de ces deux fragments c'est
l'adaptation de la grotte de drie mollen
ça veut dire que erectus
australopithèques us et
et paranthropus ont vécu en même temps
et encore une fois c'est pas une énorme
surprise puisque des traces des rictus
on en a déjà de deux millions d'années
en chine et en asie en général
d'ailleurs pas que en chine
donc on a déjà des traces d'homo erectus
de deux millions d'années voire 2
millions 1 en chine donc en asie donc
bas donc on savait déjà comment erectus
avait été contemporain de deux
australopithèques eu cette part entre
opus c'est le dire il était déjà il
était déjà en asie il ya deux millions
d'années donc évidemment qui devait être
là avant en afrique donc à la limite ça
ça cloue un peu le bec des gens qui
voulaient qui préférait voir une origine
asiatique d'homo erectus parce que du
coup qu'on avait les plus vieilles
traces qu'on avait de très vieilles
traces des rictus en asie et pas
tellement en afrique ça remettait en
question la l'origine africaine
directrice mais bon royal donc à la
limite ouais ça confirme l'origine
africaine des rictus ça confirme mais ça
réécrit rien voilà donc c'est la grande
morale de cette histoire la grande
morale de ce palier aux news c'est que
quand la prochaine fois que vous voyez
un titre
à titre put un clic qui vous dit qu'on a
réécrit une fois de plus l'évolution
humaine
c'est probablement pas le cas voilà
c'était paléo news je vous remercie de
l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner pour ne rien manquer d'anciens
et à très bientôt
[Musique]